there's KN battling along the in boards Matthews
in support righted to Center Marner tips it across
BR a shot three bound and it ricocheted off the as
sokin sends it off to the corner former Lea piing
ball and his first return back here that's off the
post to knock it down and then a nice play out of
the corner to perfect position and Adam pel ahead
that's too far for Lee after it goes orbat gets it
to pelic he shot off the Blocker of samsonov in
front back to boock and now barzel puts it back
to the line that's bought off get the Shoulder
of Samson off another stop by Samson off and I
hope all our panel guys on there been a weekend
had him on Team Canada in two years Here Comes
Matthew KN n is in and a walker stick side stop
by soken the pocket of his old teammate Matthews
in to help Bo Brock Nelson's got it it'll come
across to Mayfield here's the shot and ssov got
a piece of that unable to cash at the back door
good little stick there by pelet here's tamarus
walking in the rebound tamarus stopped again loose
of the side of the net just play to The Islander
line dos it ahead off the seed to now it's neander
forc man in GL stop soken will hold on redirected
that high and just off the target good read by
Mayfield though he stayed with his man and he
was able to get a stick in there so that might
have been a tack in otherwise here's barzel and
one time off the post rebound scores barzel and
is the ice breaker tonights has no chance for
that tap in and it's the speed of barzel backs
the defense off a little bit and that one time
shot off the post comes back in the perfect
way Riley gets the hard shot away you could
see Samson off slid across to try to wstr check
there and play back towards nander back in with
berzi tied up by Paso got it to berzi in Fr tarus
stopped by soken with the opening goal tarz comes
close to answering turned aside com to the near
side foring ball and that was changed Direction
samsonov with a strong Le pad to hold that out
I don't know where this actually ended up see it
hit the knee oh underneath the pad and just trying
to keep the strength of the pad down as in front
Lee's trying to poke at the puck the Puck's not
out there and available but the fact that samsonov
was we'll get clarifications coming
up so looks like the lead should get
a power play here at Mar for a
th walk again scores M Mars tied
it the four on four because of the delay of the
penalty and this is just Taris attracting three
New York Islanders look at everyone chasing
number 91 and the quick backhander Marner just
FES the shot forces P it to go down and Marner
handed it back to Riley and out to Matthews Bar
Cross great pass centered in front him down got
out of the Wheelhouse a little bit by quick Puck
movement and when the pressure's a little bit slow
developing you can see on his inside skate wasn't
able to get the quick one timer and soken withus
alone assists as Matthews is in rounded off his
numbers in Winnipeg 600 points 40th goal that pu
comes out and here is mlan Kyle mlan it scores out
of the box for his first National Hockey League
goal oh what a reaction there is he's got both
arms in the air CBU with the Great lead to the
middle and how about back fi just great composure
he makes the move once he gets Samson off down
it's getting points and it's a little bit of a
different time for him with seven of the last
nine without being able to put anything on the
board Matthews want a draw Barner spot it in front
and soken gloves stop off Matthews HS eyes gets
it to Matthews into the middle for Brody finds
Riley backand stop soken a right skate stop on
a dangerous shot by Morgan Riley just misses to
the outside Samson off makes the save after and
another Speedy leap Greer sends it around to the
near side mck there to play it back towards the
corner here comes Roberts it in stopped as Soka
makes a big save and to his left he has benah
but nice job of mccab keeping it alive watch
this little hesitation just double clutched a
bit and then soken held his ground and one of
his best attributes is the quick release that
one doson backed up off the Blocker of Soka and
now outed Center Sanders lead over to hbat kick
the away rebound and big stop by S off dumps it
in from Center Ice Ro in the corner watch there
Marner along the boards scoop great it for the
net Horvat stopped by S just holding their ground
Horvat finds himself in close again there fori
unable to find the stick to neander it's neander
front and he lost control of it now tamarus
neander s it across to make the save get on the
tape of Kneeland Lander but he gets it right back
and unable to keep control but as Mayfield's down
soken gets a piece for TW he had to go to the
maned to get a sticky given his to jordano who
had broken his so here's Matthew double post not
in at least two post did it hit crossbar as well
or not just slid right across I'm not sure it hit
the crossbar but it did just a quick Turn Around
by kniv off the Left Post oh yeah all three rang
the triangle Bells there I think Matthews couldn't
believe that after that second hit it didn't go
in now forzi up to doy here Max doy Shifty gears
good first in around and centering pass it ended
up on the Stick Of Wall play creates the passing
Lane here's the play by DOI what a great job
of beating him to the outside just cut this one
across Islanders with only eight Road WIS so
far there's a steal hit from b and a big great P
stopped by soken Islanders win the face off up the
boards pass brod and out here's Holstrom dropping
it off holmstrom shot hit the B least one for two
in the previous two games against the Islanders a
Faceoff win by tarus knee Lander to Riley s it
scores tipped in front by the captain and it's
two2 sets everything up you go D to D up top
along you got threats at both Matthews down low
looking for the deflection but tavarus as soon
as he wins he gets inside position stays on the
high slot and this is just great hand eye that
goes right underneath sokin sokin never really
got set and Morgan Riley instead of delaying for
Morgan Riley tried to feed the up the board picked
off by Nelson across it home Mar fan on that
here's a chance at for those some rebound scores
the Islanders get it back at it's Pierre egall
with the goahead goal against his former team
instead of making a direct pass it's D to D and
Morgan Riley on his back hand tries to go up but
it's Brock Nelson who keeps it alive there's the
opportunity for PA Mar he misses it back to nson
and then right on the doorstep you know once you
make that turnover now you're chasing the game and
this line that I mentioned hadn't done all that
much finally able to pay dirt and a got who's had
Jam in the corner Riley stepping in PR it Loose
toar short side they Jam away in front up with
it Riley KNE Lander from distance and soken now a
dozen seconds to go KNE Lander back in in the SLO
tarz couldn't reach it Riley another whack and
it's kept out big play s roken and now the pist